we all love living here in southern
nevada but the sticker shock of car
insurance always astounding and the bad
news rates have increased since last
year we take a closer look at what we
pay here and why
the zebra released its 2022 state of
auto insurance report showing a 3
percent increase in national car
insurance rates due to reckless driving
behaviors car related thefts and claims
filed due to extreme weather events and
while las vegas area drivers saw a
smaller increase compared to the
national one at an additional two
percent
since last year insurance expert ali
byers for the zebra says we still pay a
lot more than our neighbors for las
vegas specifically what we've seen is
speeding has been way up there's been an
increase in reckless driving
car theft has been up the average annual
premium for las vegas drivers this year
is at 2088 bucks compare that to reno at
1480 we're even paying more than drivers
out of los angeles they're at 2053 bucks
annually
generally when you see insurance
premiums increase it's a clue that more
people are filing claims in the area and
the following also impacts just how much
you pay who you are so your age and
credit in some states where you are all
the way down to the zip code what you
drive the make model and age of your car
and how you drive so your tickets and
your accidents speaking of where you
live drivers in the following zip codes
in our state pay the most for car
insurance in north las vegas zip code
89030
forks over an annual premium of 2562
bucks and the zip codes in las vegas of
89101 89102-104-106
pay between
2564 and 2610 bucks for an annual
premium